oh well here's something that's going to
make you feel really good guess who I
just secured as the headliner for the
Unity Concert chip mccaff no yes wait no
I don't want to touch your hand chip
mccapp is the most amazing 17 year old
country singer in the entire world he's
like Indiana's sweetheart we are huge
Chipmunks that's what uh his fans call
themselves I don't know why Chipmunks
because the animal no that's too simple
yeah okay his latest song beautiful like
my mom parentheses support the troops
has like 2 million hits on YouTube
[Music]
fancy Tran she's just she's just I'm
from Old South Bend
get home safe boys and
acting our freedom
let's play it again I'll bring the girls
you bring the beer
and the troops will bring the freedom
all right guys here's the deal
we gotta completely start over I wrote a
new song it's called the promise of
tomorrow's Wings it's brilliant about a
billion times better than catch your
dreams which I realize Now sucks ass hey
Chuck go ahead and just uh delete
everything all right hold on Chuck just
listen to the song one more time and
then make a decision
[Music]
where's that saxophone coming from I
don't know I don't know the first thing
about music
oh is that a new mix sounds way better
see just needed to clear your head
hey you guys who is this this looks just
like
oh that was loud
okay
here's the situation your parents
the brand new Porsche
[Music]
and maybe show it off to a couple of
friends I'll just cruise around the
neighborhood
good yeah of course I should
imagine here's the thick of the plot
pulled up to the corner at the end of my
block that's when I saw this beautiful
girly girl walking I picked up my car
phone to perpetrate like I was talking
sunroof is open the music was high in
that girl's hand was steadily moving up
my thigh she had opened up three buttons
on her shirt so far I guess that's why I
didn't notice that police car I can't I
can't believe it I made a mistake the
parents are the same no matter time nor
place so to all you kids all across the
land no need to argue parents just don't
understand
all right
thank you thank you
just a little something I know
so what's up uh someone is on fire in
ramsit park they need you to get down
there right away
oh my god
oh man I love this song
[Music]
[Applause]
what is this living out my dream playing
a show with the greatest band ever
that's my guitar you bought it back from
sewage Joe
I actually stole it from his office
but whatever he's a weirdo
maybe April doesn't think that we're the
greatest fan in the world but man she
loves me and I love her so you know who
cares I got the greatest wife in the
world
we're married
[Music]
[Applause]
we're totally gonna do it later oh my
God
[Applause]
okay are you ready for you to tell me
what's going on with Chris yes no to
sing if you're lost you can look and you
will find me
Time After Time go no tell me about
Chris if you fall I will catch you I'll
be waiting tell me about Chris or I'm
leaving and I don't care about the
letter
I want to have a baby and I asked Chris
to donate his sperm and he's taking a
really long time to make up his mind and
it's really freaking me out and I can't
stop thinking about it and I'm obsessing
about it I want to think about anything
else but that but it's making me crazy
secrets
stolen
from deep inside you know the song
already of course I do everyone knows a
song it's amazing the drum beats out of
time if you're lost you can look and you
will find me Time After Time
if you fall I will catch you oh I've
been waiting Time After Time Time After
Time Time After Time
good stuff it's never happened
jackpot
you know what this is Ron this is a mix
I made for the summer Parts barbecue
2007. I asked everyone in the parks
department to choose one song you chose
buddy by Willie Nelson a fact I remember
because my mind is a steel trap of
friendship nuggets but I am not going to
play your choice
I'm gonna play Jerry's choice
oh that's right and I'm gonna sing along
and I'm gonna maintain eye contact the
whole time and guess what I'm
hurts Harry Truman was the guy America
red China all the countries other people
Everyone is fun Joe Montana
I have to buy new toaster this is
awesome you're so stupid jumping up and
down
oh I got it on repeat tomorrow you want
to hear it again or you want to talk no
okay next first Freddy Krueger bought
some pants Oprah has a turtle farm Peter
Piper pee pee poopy daddy concert
I love this town so much and I'm just so
proud to live here
and we're gonna close tonight out with a
tribute the pawnee's greatest treasure
[Music]
[Applause]
said goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
faster
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen Mr Duke Silva
[Applause]
[Music]
this city
thank you
foreign